ce chantier
donc on a commencé en fin d'année
dernière c'est de ce chantier qui est à
la phase 1 la phase ii structurantes des
travaux de la zac polytechnique donc
l'idée c'est de viabiliser tous ces
terrains qui étaient plutôt à vocation
agricole à l'origine et donc d'être dans
les temps pour que tous les bâtiments
qui vont se montrer si puisse être
alimenté en eau en énergie en réseau et
par ailleurs ont pris l on prépare
l'avenir c'est à dire qu'on prépare le
cadre dans lequel tous les futurs lots
futurs habitants futures entreprises qui
annoncent installés ici tiendront sera
accordée dans le cadre le plus agréable
possible
cette opération est particulière pour
plusieurs raisons d'une part son ampleur
pas accès de 130 hectares deuxième
particularité les habitants parce qu'on
a l'impression que le paysage est très
vite mais on a des riverains très très
particulier qui sont les centres de
recherche de danone des centres de
recherche de thales des nanotechnologies
au sud qui sont extrêmement exigeants
qui ont des problématiques très
particulières liées par exemple à des
vibrations à des mesures qu'ils font et
c'est tout un aspect des travaux qui est
assez spécifique à ce chantier
là nous sommes sur le bassin dit numéro
3 qui constitue un maillon de la chaîne
hydraulique de gestion des eaux de
ruissellement et de préservation contre
les inondations
le tableau des vallées par rapport aux
urbanisation qui vont venir sur le
quartier de l'école polytechnique et la
partie écologique environnementale des
projets c'est un chantier qui est des
mariés maintenant 9 mois avec un feu 23
euros prévue pour fin août 15 15
septembre
ces bassins crée donc en périphérie des
milieux qui permettront de reconstituer
des lieux qui ont été détruits par le
projet qui vont l'être pour que le
projet soit le moins impactant possible
des milieux et donc là on s'éloigne de
la question purement hydraulique pour
s'intéresser à l'autre volet de la
question qui une question plus
écologique et plus liées à la
préservation et à la reconstitution des
millions qu'on a la zac à des truites
aura détruit s'agit de construire un
campus à échelle mondiale à envergure
mondiale et donc ça donne une pression
en tout cas une émulation collective
assez fort pour réussir ce campus en
respectant à la fois l'environnement
déjà existants et donner la dimension
mondiale de ce cette zone